hello and welcome back to round six of
the sink pill cup and as you can see
it's we have a very special guest in the
studio Dr Paula Knight who is the
superintendent of schools in the
Jennings School District district and
you are a staunch advocate for the
Scholastic chess initiative oh yes yes
and tell us how is the school year going
and tell us about your school district
yeah so the school Year is off to a
really really good start so we are at
that time of year where we are coasting
into the holiday season so right
everyone has on their wings we're
coasting but to start out this year this
was probably one of the smoothest starts
that we had to this school year um you
know I'm going into my third year as a
superintendent and often times the
research says third year for
superintendent you can kind of start
seeing everything fall into place okay
and so um so we've had a really good
year really good year how many kids are
in the Jennings School District
approximately 2500 wow 500 um really
really super proud of the fact that you
know we've expanded Early Childhood so
we're getting kids as early as 3 years
old okay and they are going to school uh
and they're in school all day every
single day so uh so we're growing so
just growing the district and just
really getting out here and getting back
on the map and in the school district
how many get exposure to the chess oh my
goodness um this the program has touched
hundreds of kids um and that's the whole
intent right that is the intent and then
starting early getting them in getting
them in early um early exposure um mean
you don't have to be afraid of Chess and
sometimes you know you hear people say
oh my gosh when it comes to chess I
don't know how to play but when you
expose children early and then having a
consistent plan of exposure goes a long
way absolutely as we see some of the uh
Boll there yeah you can see some of the
children learning chess that I me this
is such a wonderful site to see but uh
well recently a a research study was
completed in your District about how
chess positively impacts your students
what were the key takeaways from the
study the key takeaways two big
takeaways the first one was mathematics
and um the ability to solve problems and
so that's critical thinking and that's
what chest really you know um instills
with in the player you know how to take
your time and think um and within
mathematics when they take their
assessment every year there's a lot of
word problems where they have to really
think through the problem and then the
second is um the discipline infractions
we've seen our discipline infractions go
down they've almost plummeted right um
because you know with chess it also um
teaches kids how to regulate themselves
that self-regulation and to take their
time and to you know
self-discipline um and those are the key
takeaways um and and kids are coming to
school every day right right so you know
we talk about coming to school we talk
about teaching and learning they're in
school especially on the days they know
they have chess exactly and so it has
yes and so it has gone through the roof
when we talk about our attendance um but
it's it's been phenomenal well that's
very unexpected takeaway for me actually
that's
it certainly impacted on the attendance
rat absolutely absolutely I always uh
used chess As a treat uh I raised in
Seattle Washington and went to mini uh
middle school and Garfield High School
and I was actually a chess teacher at
the meanie middle school and the kids
came and for me one of the things that
was really wonderful about Chess and
introducing chess to to uh kids was it
forced them to read because chess you
have to write down your moves and then
you know I want to beat Joie so I'll go
get a chess book and I would read the
chess book to try to get ahead and learn
a trick or two that maybe she didn't
know so for me chess was a real treat in
the Reading
Writing era fascinating areas I love it
I love it wonderful well thank you so
much for joining oh sorry you have one
more question please question you're not
getting away Dr KN not it as long as you
need
because we do have the strategy across
the board Gala coming up on December
thei which supports the Scholastic chess
initiative and what does it mean to have
such a support for your students yeah so
you know this is you know this is almost
personal for me right because when we're
talking about children um black children
um who come from varying economic
backgrounds um you know it's important
to always EXP Expose and to expose early
and with the Gaya it shows that there's
a continuation of support um within our
district so much so that we are able to
possibly look at expanding right um you
know I have really been a staunch
proponent of uh girls in chess black
girls in chess um boys black boys and so
this gives us the opportunity it it
tells me the community is behind school
districts and ensuring that doesn't go
anywhere chess is here to stay right and
that we can have chess it doesn't have
to be after school it's part of our
instructional day and we can continue
that same pattern and so with the Gaya
and you know seeing hundreds of people
come out in support it tells me that
they are indeed supporting school
districts to ensure that this you know
it's not an initiative this is a fabric
of what we do um when we offer chess and
there we have it on our screen that
Saturday December second here in the
Central West End uh we will be having
that very special Gayla and it's our big
big fundraising uh event for uh the
schools as we said yeah absolutely
beautifully said that thank you very
much Dr Knight for joining us here in
the studio and talking about how chess
impacts in your Scholastic District
thank you thank you thank you again and
here are our standings as we are in
round